wait till we're live
stand by
hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom live stream sorry running a
little bit late as you can see i am in a
different location i think i finally got
the wi-fi fixed in the house uh so we're
going to try this you might hear some
screaming kids every now and then but
that just allowed a little bit of flavor
to the experience uh exciting a show
today uh but before we get into the
thick of it i will explain uh for those
of y'all who might just be showing up
for the first time what this thing is
uh khan academy we're not for profit and
our mission is to provide a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and when we saw it seems like a
lifetime ago but now five six seven
weeks ago that we had these mass school
closures not just in the us but around
the world we saw given our mission given
that we've been creating uh content and
tools to support parents teachers
students for the last 10 years that it's
really our duty to step up even more
during this crisis and so above and
beyond all the learning materials
that'll hopefully keep folks learning
we've been trying to do parent webinars
teacher webinars this live stream just
as a way to stay in touch
as we go through the conversation very
exciting conversation today i encourage
you put questions for either myself or
our guest who is a super teacher
on either facebook or youtube and we
have team members who are looking at
those i do like to remind folks khan
academy as i said is a not-for-profit we
exist because of philanthropic donations
if you're in a position to do so please
think about donating to khan academy i
do want to give special thanks to
several corporate partners who've
stepped up in the last few weeks
to allow us to do this work we've been
running at a deficit even before the
crisis and you can imagine our costs
have gone up we're seeing three times
the server load that we typically see
and we're trying to accelerate a lot of
programs so special thanks to bank of
america google.org att fastly novartis
and uh we need more help so anyone out
there uh who who wants to help us out
more either as an individual donor or as
a corporation please reach out so with
that would love to get into the core of
the program i'd love to introduce connor
corey who's an incredible teacher from
the centennial school district in
pennsylvania uh connor great to have you
here
thanks so i'm excited to be here
and first of all this is the launch of
teacher appreciation week so let me just
tell you i think we all appreciated
teachers before this or hopefully we
should be uh and you're a super teacher
who we've been appreciating for many
years and i think for many of us parents
who now have to handle our own kids in
our house the level of teacher
appreciation has gone up
i agree with you
very many positive emails from parents
um that appreciate the help as they're
confused and stressed out as many of us
are during this time
yeah so maybe a good place to start uh
you know you're what's known as a khan
academy teacher ambassador you know tell
us a little bit about
what you teach tell us about your kids
tell us about um how you've been using
khan academy and what this means to be
an ambassador
so um i s this is my 17th year teaching
and i spent majority of my career
teaching
sophia school district and that's where
i really described
we're pretty underfunded um and we many
of our students
they didn't have a learning disability
but they were maybe a year or a few
years behind and khan academy always
gave me the ability to
remediate content without having to file
paperwork or go find a different book
but it was always like three act
and from there i kind of continued to
make a lot
larger and larger part of the curriculum
and when the ambassador program came out
a few years ago i applied to that and
it's been fantastic there is you know
right now we have a thousand over a
thousand people that donate their time
to help other teachers to show them
um just different ways to access a
variety of education when i first
started it was just math but it has
become so much more and just you know
parents that are using it
in high school college it's really
been a huge help for not only the
education system
for the world so
i mean there's i will always fully
support this program maybe not
financially but with my time
no the way that you're the way you're
supporting it is as essential as
anything and we really consider you a
you know a close part of this khan
academy team i think one of the things
that has really you know you stood out
uh as an ambassador for khan academy you
know obviously we put those resources
out there and we have efficacy studies
that if students are able to put in the
time they're able to accelerate their
learning but the key question that we've
been trying to answer this many people
have been asking this in in this live
stream and other places is well how do
we motivate kids to do it especially
they're at home now it's not the same as
being in a classroom what are your well
what we what were your techniques before
kovid and then what tips do you have for
parents and teachers and even students
themselves to stay motivated during this
crisis
uh motivation's always been fun for me
um
while i was teaching i always looked at
it as our students are so drastically
different and come from different
backgrounds i could
buy an xbox and put that surprise but
then there's a kid in the class that has
two xboxes that doesn't motivate him so
i always found that embarrassing
yourself as an adult for a child or what
they can't purchase
is something that will motivate all of
them so over the years during learnstorm
we've had kids throw water balloons at
us we did something called the wheel
doom where with 26 teachers signed up in
the winning class each kid spawned this
wheel and
whatever it landed on mustard mayonnaise
we had a whole assembly they were
able to squirt that in the teacher's
face i've all for
kind of laughs we had even our
one teacher and our vice principal let
us wax our legs with wax strips as a
reward
which we're running out of ideas that
you could tell
you are a dedicated teacher
i have this sense of viewer of a middle
school kid so or maybe your legs would
not be quite as painful as mine i am
anyway
we're just trying to do the same things
and trying to keep it that interaction
with the students
we did yesterday they finished tied how
many many of the parents were nervous
they weren't prepared for seventh grade
math i teach six-week math so they're
very nervous with everything that's
happened so
we i spent a week and only assigned them
growth mindset activities that we did
earlier in the year during learnstorm
and i wanted to reinforce that at this
time
and then the last week i gave them
seventh grade assignments without much
teaching there was i was kind of like
you have the background knowledge and
when you try these things a few times
times remember you're going to get them
wrong remember the fact that's what we
did last week the first mindset and if
you
have fish
you know
i have studied with students
and i will do the
one at the blender challenge and
i would blend up seven things in my
fridge and drink it on camera for them
and we had parents sign up also
i told them to sign their parents up but
today i've watched like eight different
videos of parents laughing with their
kids blending up disgusting things in
the fridge
all for math just to kind of get them
laughing again and
sit around
we've been trying to do stupid stuff
like that and i have a student now
giving me requests i have two rules it
has to be free and legal those are my
only tools and i'll do it
that's very i love that because you know
we always talk about motivation we
usually think it has to be some deep
psychological mind trick that you play
with kids or maybe we do do we do defer
to kind of the the not as healthy uh
rewards like here's some sugar here's
some you know
not so good screen time but what you're
saying this is really fun it's these
memorable quirky you just have to have a
little bit of a willingness to
you know subject yourself to the whim of
a child you you accomplish this i as
your or your or your or your teacher i'm
willing to
do what you what you want something fun
quirky
as long as it's legal and and no one
gets hurt so to speak
it's so yeah
and related to that you know this first
question from facebook scott yang asks
hi connor how does it feel to teach from
home so you described kind of what you
were doing pre-covid i i am curious i
think a lot of teachers and parents are
curious so how are you keeping that same
or or can you keep that same level of
energy or connectedness with your
students right now how are you trying to
do that
i'm trying to i don't i don't believe
it's possible to do the same way because
i can't see my students face live as i'm
i'm kind of recording lessons and
sending them and answering questions
when they record something back
but i know when i'm in class when you
know jake does nothing and i'm talking
he has no idea what i'm talking about i
have to kind of step in there but i can
see you know when
one student doesn't sit with the friends
they usually sit with that maybe they're
having a bad day and something's going
on and it's teachers we're aware of
those things and we really try to focus
on that social piece just as much
and it's very difficult
this way how and it's also with
i mean i'm fortunate enough to still
have
my employment but many of our parents
have lost that and there's kids i four
children of my own throughout the house
i can't believe they haven't interrupted
yet but they are usually
we're trying to get everything organized
while i'm teaching as well and sharing
devices so
it's it is difficult and it's high
stress and i think as parents we need to
kind of give ourselves
a break
from
making sure every little thing is done
and
how are you handling personally i mean
you know being able to keep your
students engaged your full-time job
trying to teach virtually however you
can at the same time for
kids at home
how are you able to navigate that
personally
personally i think i'm doing okay like
we i have a great family of a loving
wife very supportive and
i
try to keep my mindset and find the
positives in things that are going on
and the positives of getting this much
time with my children and my family and
to really focus on
better the many negatives that you can
see on news and many things
as they're going on here in pennsylvania
as we have severely high cases of covid
and you hear
stories of grandparents and parents and
hospitals that are overrun and people
are unfortunately passing away
i think it's a good learning
opportunity for my children to kind of
you know work on ourselves and make sure
that we're
just trying to stay upbeat to
give yourself time i mean it's okay to
meditate and give yourself 20 minutes to
think before your day starts it's
very helpful
and i think that helps people get
through the stress
and what kind of a tempo are you having
with your students now like
are you recommending so these are sixth
graders you're recommending them do a
certain amount of khan academy or get
certain goals it sounds like you're also
recording some of your own lessons are
you also trying to do some zoom or
google me what are the different ways
how does that work right now for you
with your students
me so the lesson will be on khan academy
where i use
whatever topic like we were doing
circumference last week so i will kind
of teach it on this little board back
here you know it looks like i'm in a
fancy classroom but i'm actually in my
basement
but i'll teach that and then they can
record videos back to me and i can kind
of answer their questions one to one and
then i can see how they're doing on the
assignments
that i send to them and through because
i'm
able to track that data i'm able to also
set challenges will hit me
the assignments done or i have them
setting personal goals for themselves to
work on and that's where i'll use the
time piece more than the actual
assignments since they're on various
levels
yeah and what advice would you have i
mean i thought you had some really good
personal advice on just how all of us
could
navigate the situation what advice do
you have for other teachers there that
are feeling a little bit overwhelmed
like
how do you navigate this how do you keep
your kids learning uh can you even try
to do what you would typically do in a
normal environment
i think if
you focus on one platform
something that they're familiar with
every teacher is getting things from
their district
try this try this just as every parent
is getting
a million new apps that they're able to
use or a million different ways to
find curriculum that aligns but it's so
overwhelming for not only the teacher
who hasn't had to use maybe the digital
textbook or hasn't had to use some of
these digital things but also for the
parent when they have
unfortunately
for them
and connor
connor your your your connection's
chopping chopping up a bit which is
unfortunate maybe we'll we'll bring you
on a little bit um
i think it just got a little bit worse
but what we'll do is i'll i'll wind down
here i'll tell everyone uh please feel
free to ask questions for either myself
or connor and i'll go into kind of a
little bit of a ask me anything mode uh
but connor
if if your internet is not choppy you
know any any parting thoughts for folks
uh on how to on how to teach or learn
maybe what message would you have for
students in this environment
who are trying to learn at the same time
deal with everything else
i think trying to learn this environment
you really have to
focus on growth mindset and for our
older students to look through
concavity's career section i think
that is a fantastic way to see a linear
path of
what you possibly want to do after high
school and those steps for them and for
them to see the steps they need to take
is valuable to know that what they have
to do now to achieve that and kind of
the self learning that they're
that's going on
all over the globe
currently
yeah
no conor thank thank you so much and uh
i hope we can continue this conversation
uh when the internet gods
give us more
better conditions i've been there myself
many times
so thank you so much connor
thank you
so uh
this you know as you all can see this is
a very authentic show we do here where
uh we're all dealing with the
complexities of uh uh being socially
distanced uh but i if anyone anyone has
questions i'm happy to answer them in in
kind of classic uh ask me anything style
uh you know one thing that connor
mentioned a couple of times that i'm
sure a lot of y'all are focused on but
essentially something i think about is a
growth mindset how does he give growth
mindsets to his students or how does he
even have one himself and that's just
this notion that you either believe
you're good at certain things and not
good at certain things that's a fixed
mindset or you think you have a growth
mindset the only way you know what
you're good at is by pushing yourself
and failing and reflecting on those
failures and trying again really pushing
yourself out of your comfort zone and
disproportionately in any field the
people who do well aren't necessarily
the people who had a strong starting
point they're the people who have a
growth mindset who are always pushing
themselves out of their comfort zone and
the more you realize that the more you
realize that your brain is like a muscle
the more you use it the stronger it gets
that it's actually when you fail and you
reflect on that failure that you form
the most neural connections you actually
are getting smarter in that way when you
fail that you can really start to
exercise that that growth mindset uh so
it's a super important idea that we talk
a lot about in in this live stream
so we're
uh
we're getting some questions
looks like these are for me from
facebook kazi akash amith asks greeting
mr khan how does khan academy help you
make up your life i mean you have to
spend your your part of life for others
i hope it gets answered
um
well you're getting answered
so that that hope is hope is coming true
you know uh it's i think generous when
people say oh sal you you're you're
putting time your life for khan academy
but for me i consider myself the
luckiest person on the planet uh i don't
think there's a more rewarding thing
that i can do
i get to work with an incredible team i
get to work with incredible uh
teachers like the one that you just saw
and administrators to try to help
millions or tens or hundreds of millions
of students over time learn so
i think it's a very fortunate thing that
you know i i pinch myself that i get to
work on this especially considering you
know 10 years ago 11 years ago i was
just one guy in a walk-in closet the
fact that khan academy now has so many
other people uh being able to help and
so many people who are hopefully
benefiting from it makes a huge deal in
terms of balancing i think that's just a
trick in life
you heard
the teacher just now talk a little bit
about that
but it's uh
you know when when you care passionately
about a mission that's valuable but it
can easily become all-encompassing so
one thing that i work on in my life is
you know how do i balance these two
things how do i make sure that i always
have time for my family time for my kids
where my brain isn't talking of thinking
about
the next thing at khan academy the next
thing to do uh where i can really be
present in the moment uh that's i think
the best way of of kind of of having a a
balance
so
from youtube sebastian ruiz asks how do
you cope with all the things going on
so
you know a lot of people these days
whenever you get on a phone call with
anyone they're like oh well how are you
doing in the crisis and my answer has
been i think this is
this is hard on everyone but relatively
speaking i'm very very lucky uh i have
my job
i
my obviously my wife is super supportive
my mother-in-law lives with us and so
together and my my children's teachers
are doing heroic jobs amazing jobs uh at
keeping our kids learning and staying
engaged so that combination of support
is really really valuable as you know
we're trying to work from home and
sometimes your five-year-old might be
having a tantrum
most of the time there we can kind of
have each other's backs and and and take
care of each other
i think that plus you know i've talked
about it this live stream before
i do a lot of meditation i've been doing
it for about a year and a half now and
the meditation really can help you not
get caught up in some of the stresses
that this crisis might be putting on
folks the other thing i say is you know
try to focus on what is in your zone of
control what you actually can
help do
sometimes you can get very overwhelmed
by what's going on in the broader world
so it is useful of course to know what's
going on watch the news but don't do too
much of that because if you do too much
of that you can start to feel very
powerless and very helpless so say
what's in my zone of control what can i
do you know to quote frozen to what's
the next right thing to do uh and and
just try to do that but you know as as
was just said you know there is a silver
lining i'm able to spend a lot more time
with
my kids with my wife you know between
meetings i can
make the bed or do some dishes or go for
a walk so there is a bit of a silver
lining there i think there's some family
time some down time that is happening
that otherwise otherwise there's it's
always a go go go type of situation
so
from
youtube afton aftonkid12 says hey sal
what is the best way to learn honors
algebra one as a sixth grader in school
well what i would do
is well there's a couple of things if
you're a sixth grader i would go to khan
academy and if you've already mastered
sixth grade or if you find it easy go to
the seventh grade course on khan academy
and if you think you can accelerate
through that you can use the course
challenges which you can take as many
times as you want to accelerate through
things you can take unit tests and then
as you accelerate through that do eighth
grade and eighth grade uh actually has a
lot of overlap with algebra one but then
go through eighth grade and then you can
go into the into the algebra one on khan
academy now if you feel like you're
prepared you could go straight to
algebra one uh try to engage in those
first units and if it's making sense
keep going
but what i would say is try to find what
you need use the course challenges to
and unit tests to accelerate as
necessary and then the most important
thing is make a habit out of it and this
is advice for everyone regardless of
whether you're tackling third grade math
algebra one or calculus or biology
whatever as long as you're able to put
consistently 20 30 40 minutes in a day
over time and let's say you're able to
do that at least four or five days a
week over time you're going to see that
pays huge huge huge dividends
other more i guess tactical advice i
would have is focus on the practice get
that mastery but the videos are
obviously there due to help you but the
best way to watch videos is not to watch
them passively is to watch them actively
so
think about you know if a problem shows
up in the video pause the video many
times in the videos i make i tell you
pause the video do that try to work it
out on your own if uh once i say i'm
making the video and you you see it's
worked through
try to pause it see if you can do it
yourself on your own and these are just
good practices these are things that i
used to do in school where if the
teacher ran through a proof or did an
example i would either try to do it
before the teacher did it on the board
it was very active or once they did it i
would then not look at their work and
try to see if i could replicate their
thought process so if you have that
active learning with the videos you
worked on the exercises you put that 30
40 minutes a day you don't stop learning
you keep learning through the summer i
have no doubt especially given that
you're asking this question and you seem
quite
eager to keep learning which is awesome
don't lose that that eagerness
i think you're going to do
just fine and you could also look at
some learning plans we have for algebra
one
you can look up
learning plans khan academy you'll see
the one for algebra one it can pace you
between now and the start of the next
school year to see how you can pace
through that but i'm confident that if
if you're if you're motivated you put
that 20 30 minutes a day in uh you're
you're going to do just fine afton kid
12.
so
kazzy amit from facebook is asking is
there any chance for online education to
replace institutional this is a
fascinating question i've been getting a
lot of this in the press lately
i think for k-12 or pre-k-12 no i i
think you know we just saw an amazing
teacher the types of experiences you can
get in a classroom
you're not going to be able to replicate
that with online and it's because
education isn't just about learning how
to factor a polynomial or learning the
steps of photosynthesis there's a whole
aspect of socialization of learning to
work with others learning to communicate
and
most students need some extra motivation
some coaching ways to get unblocked when
they get blocked there's a lot to
learning that goes beyond just
understanding uh the concepts there's a
lot that's going on at a at a
metacognitive level
and so uh you know i've i've i've said
this many times and this is you know
teacher appreciation week so i think
it's a good time to resay it if i had to
pick between an amazing teacher or
amazing technology for my own kids i
would pick an amazing teacher every time
in fact that's why i started a school
you know i started khan academy but i so
strongly believe in the physical
experience
that that we started a school that has
many amazing teachers in it so i would
pick an amazing teacher every time now
the good thing is we don't have to make
that trade-off the ideal is amazing
technology in support of amazing
teachers and so that's what everything
we do we try to do at khan academy
that's why we are so close to all of
these amazing teacher ambassadors who
give us feedback how we can be better
and it's support to allow those teachers
to
differentiate to the needs of those 30
students to understand that every
student has different levels of
preparedness learns at different rates
and to allow students to get that which
would have been very hard as a teacher
by themselves so i don't think it's a
replacement now when you get into
there are circumstances in the world
where kids in you know some war-torn
place the refugee camp where they don't
have access to school well in those
cases yes online can be a very good
thing to keep people learning there's
situations right now because of kovid
where uh certain school systems haven't
been able to support their students as
much as others well there online
learning obviously uh is a very powerful
way to keep students learning and then
as you get into
you know
almost adulthood or being a young adult
or an adult that's where i think online
learning can be very powerful
you know there's very powerful things
about going to college i have very fond
memories once again a lot of the
socialization all that but for some
young adults or even not so young adults
they might say hey i have a job i have
to support my family i need more
flexibility and that's where online
learning can be super useful so simple
answer is i hope that they can always
work together kind of a blended
experience the best of both worlds that
learning does not have to be bound by
time and space but some of the richest
experiences can happen in the physical
environment but even there part of the
richness comes from the ability to
leverage uh tools online tools like like
khan academy
so
errata irmo from youtube is asking can
you talk about taking responsibility
such as becoming a doctor but you don't
have the confidence or consistent study
habits
well errata you know i will just say
it's all about forming a habit uh it's
it's all about you know one of my good
friends from schools names charles
duhigg he wrote a very popular book uh
the power of habit but you know they're
science that habits tend to form over
let's call it five six seven weeks and
so what i would do is i would pick a
goal don't try to solve the whole goal
overnight that could be paralyzing don't
try to binge study your cram but say hey
every day i'm going to spend 20 30 40 50
minutes a day towards that goal and if
you do that for six or seven weeks
you're going to build that habit and
then you're going to see the gains and
that's going to help your confidence you
know i talked about growth mindset
before growth mindset is all about you
don't say i'm good at this or not good
at this i'm capable or not capable
you're like i just have to keep chipping
away at it i have to keep stepping out
of my comfort zone if i get something
wrong if i fail i shouldn't give up that
isn't somehow me saying oh i'm no good
at this that's when i should say oh
awesome i just learned about my learning
edge let me reflect on why i i failed
there or why i got that wrong and let me
keep trying and you will be shocked if
you just keep persevering
eventually you will get through those
barriers and you're like what that what
was the big deal there and i got to tell
you the biggest skill in life yes it's
nice to have hard skills to know how to
factor polynomial or or or science or or
or write well but the most important
thing in in life is that resiliency and
having that growth mindset if you have
that and you're always just
you keep in motion powering forward then
frankly you'll you'll be unstoppable and
i'll say another thing you know it's
very tempting especially while you're in
school we're always measured by test
scores and this and that and and there's
so much importance on them that's very
easy to assume oh i keep getting a 95
that person
you know two desks down always gets a
98.
they're always going to be better than
me because they always score better on
tests and what you see as soon as you
enter into the real world it doesn't
work out that way the people who do well
are the people with the growth mindsets
who don't give up who believe in
themselves have that resilience you know
if i go back into my own schooling and
and see you know yes doing well in
school matters and it correlates but
it's not like you should just stack rank
yourself against other people and say
okay that's the ranking that's going to
be forever it has a lot more to do with
mindset that it has to do with any you
know fixed mindset notion of of you know
quote innate ability which frankly uh i
i don't i don't really subscribe to so
anyway hope hopefully that helps and i
realize that i'm all out of time so i
just want to give a special thanks to
connor corey
amazing teacher amazing teacher
ambassador i think he had some great
advice unfortunately the sound was
clipping out a little bit
but hopefully we'll be able to get him
on in the not too far off future but i
just want to wish everyone out there
especially the amazing teachers in the
world happy teacher appreciation week uh
you do amazing work all the time and i
think in this week you can you're
continuing to do amazing work or this
time the covet time and i think many of
us parents have even higher appreciation
so
thank you for doing what you do there's
no single
higher leverage point for helping
humanity in my opinion than your ability
to empower all of our our collective
children
so with that thank you so much and i
look forward to seeing all of y'all at
the live stream tomorrow
you